[Music]
drunk
listen guys i want to talk to you about
adamandeve.com okay you know we're sex
positive here over at lifeline and the
super cult studios but look it's a lot
of bad news out there about prices these
days it's nice to know that adam and eve
is still offering the best deal still
adamandeve.com
go there and get 50 off plus
as if that's not enough dude free
shipping free shipping and fifty percent
fifty percent
an adventurous new toy okay a slippery
lube or almost anything else you desire
could be anything else right yeah so our
podcast listeners will get 50 off almost
every
item just use code lifeline at checkout
and you'll get 50 off and free shipping
it doesn't matter what you choose
all will be packaged and sent discreetly
for free you know we're sex positive but
we get it it's sensitive and maybe you
don't want the box to say adam and eve
it doesn't it's super discreet not only
we save money on gas movies and date
night dinners out yeah but this is the
item that will continue to save you
money deliver tons of fun and
satisfaction are you non-stop on-call
yeah it's like are you uh are you
romantic or not yeah yeah you are so go
to adam and eve
uh and select any one item use code
lifeline that's l-i-f-e-l-i-n-e
is an exclusive offer specific to this
podcast so be sure to support our show
that's how you support our show you go
on there and you use the code lifeline
to get you
not just the 50 off but also the 100
free shipping code lifeline go to
adamandeve.com right now
right now
lifeline is an advice show for
entertainment purposes only if you need
real help or advice please seek a
therapist or a licensed professional
[Music]
hello
hello
[Music]
did we start do i start i got something
to talk about at the time no no no yes i
do but we talk about honestly it's
it's not necessarily like i have so you
do the rules and you set the pace i have
to do it organically baby
okay are we going are we going did we
start yeah it started okay well bill
o'reilly bill relax we'll do it live uh
so last episode we made a mistake and a
mistake not me yeah you actually i did
you're right so when you asked me is is
you you did breathe in breathe out the
bush thing
yeah
yeah and then i said and then i said did
machine machine head yeah and i said
they're different songs i know and
they're not different songs
breathe in breathe out breathe in
breathe out breathe in breathing
breathing
got a machine head it's better than the
rest green dude
machine head got a machine here man it's
better than the rest the green dudes
retention all right now i'm sweating
well yeah dude you can't start off like
part of my apology
it was my apology tour dude no look i
already knew the facts behind that but i
don't
why didn't you say it when i got i know
i do it because i don't care dude i
don't care much you don't care about the
facts this isn't advice no i care about
the facts but i know the facts okay so
it's like
people can think what they want man
there's also two sides to every story
you know what i mean i want to be
cleared up for gavin rossdale so we
interrupted me but it's fine the band
bush and bush fans alike yeah all right
so look man
um things have been going crazy well for
me
and uh it's fine right and so
i don't know like my nose feels good i
can kind of breathe a little bit more
breathe in breathe out and uh
i used to when i would clog this one
yeah
i'd almost pass out if i did it for too
long and now i do it i have a hard time
you can hear it
oh i'm gonna die if i do if i don't move
my thumb
you'd pass out you think
and then you pass out and then i just do
the rest of it and it's basically
congratulations
so listen dude um
we sing too much on this podcast
disagree all right you don't think we
sing enough i want to turn it into a s
to an advice
musical advice
advice
singing podcast i'm gonna be in dallas
i'm gonna be in dallas august 26th yeah
like that i'm going to be in wichita
august 27th then i'm going to be in
atlanta and washington dc and stockton
cali and then oakland peoria illinois
rockford illinois raleigh and savannah
georgia denver and cheyenne boston twice
because people from boston love your boy
so go to crystalia.com and get all those
tickets also i'll be in albany and
lakeland florida even though that's a
place that's made up and doesn't exist
and then jacksonville why for some
reason but i'm going to be there
and uh and that's that dude
and i'll be hitting all the [ __ ]
cities and everyone keeps saying no dude
you're not gonna come to chicago you're
not gonna come to new york and i got a
question for you do you understand how
time works yeah cause it keeps going
yeah and i could keep going places do
you think i'm only gonna do a 17 cities
tour
no dude not me you're not gonna only do
a seven dude i do 70 cities and [ __ ]
what do they say i find new cities that
har i find colonies i perform in that
just [ __ ] got created in [ __ ] oh okay
well what do they say when they say why
aren't you playing in new york do they
just say that they go come on man do i
really have to travel to [ __ ] and
it's like dude no just wait dude people
go people are like oh man i got tickets
for dallas and now i just found out
you're going to be in albany i was going
to fly to dallas and see you and it's
like just wait yeah cause time wait
somebody was gonna lived in new york was
gonna know what i don't know this is an
example but yes that does happen yes yes
that does happen yes yes yes that does
happen yes okay yes it does
um so this is lifeline the [ __ ]
critically acclaimed podcast um yeah and
uh we have not submitted it for any
awards
coming up though
we might sweep we're better than that
dude
we don't compete yeah
and uh so yeah look take a moment if you
like the podcast subscribe to super cult
studios
because we've got this we've got
congratulations that we've got more
[ __ ] podcasts coming out and
subscribe and hit that bell notification
thing you know what i mean baby
so
so yeah do it um anyway we're having a
good time and now how's the big one with
you
oh good taking too long to answer so
a [ __ ] barbara walters on a bad day
like it's [ __ ] what's it called uh
james little you asked me a question i
was [ __ ] thinking about it okay good
and the answer is
i've been having a mixed week and the
reason i've been having a mixed week is
because it started monday then i went to
thursday and then it became tuesday
no uh
dad everyone was flipping out about me
singing on the last episode loving it
thinking it was great mistaking me for
ketus no but
as i already said i went on to miss mis
uh
mistake the bush thing right and i felt
terrible about that
and so i wanted to address it at the top
of the show and sing it because
everybody loves when i sing they don't
though no they do
we'll do a poll everyone write in tell
me how much you love it when i sing how
about this dude if you don't like it
tell me and we'll see we'll we'll add up
how about this since you're already done
subscribing to super cult studios
how about this in the comments who's a
better singer and who would you rather
like hearing signs that's good and we'll
tally them up and at the end you'll do
that do that day [ __ ] and i'll do the
[ __ ] you know the day got a machine i
am
getting poked in the butt
by a [ __ ] a really really large
[ __ ] object well so uh
i don't know dude you know i drove here
and it's all good and my nose feels good
and i feel [ __ ] excited about that
now when you said you drove here yeah
obviously you drove here you drive
everywhere you drive here every time
why'd you why'd you even say it
why'd you even say i just i just you
know it was like
dead space but instead i said i drove
here okay well how have you been how's
your week going it's going well man my
nose is good and i [ __ ] slept i
didn't sleep well last night dude i kept
waking up every [ __ ] hour and a half
i got this new cbd [ __ ] though i'm gonna
try no thc so many [ __ ] letters the
last
10 double acp seven
days the last 10 12 days i haven't slept
at all last night i finally got some
sleep and it's because one up to me i
took some [ __ ] thc slash c so many
letters got it from the n double h
and it gave me and then s p c c and then
i played my ps5 and um come from the p a
c slash one zero sec all right dude uh
enough of it
so look
uh you did do cbd
uh i do it all
but i did do it did you rub it in your
face or what do you do you could think
of the crazy stuff yeah oh yes it does
dude dude you can do cbd in anyway it's
crazy like they're like would you like a
tincture or would you like to take it in
pill form or would you like to put it up
your anus or would you like to rub it we
have face lotion they'll be like we have
a cbd shirt if you'd like to wear it
you'll be very calm all day i do the cbd
with the weed because i want to get high
but i also the cbd really helps me sleep
oh oh problems no it's all good
it's all good it's all good but what the
[ __ ]
oh
drug addict
got too close to me yeah you almost lost
your fingers no yep so uh well let's get
into it dude all right
hi you know what i keep thinking about
is the guy who died in the middle yeah
you love the guy oh my god dude last
episode when the guy died in the middle
of his
thing and came back to life oh
what this guy dude what is this hold on
is this a couple in a tv show what the
[ __ ] why because it's a mixed race
because it's white a white and a black
guy you walk around you don't see mixed
couples they're
but then you turn on [ __ ]
true oh you walk around you don't see
mixed couples dudes exist
they [ __ ] should be a plenty right
because it's la and we're a melting pot
but you go to fort wayne indiana it's
only whites together and then some
blacks together dude if you walk around
l.a there's not enough mixture will you
turn on the tv dude if you [ __ ] turn
on the tv and it goes to a commercial
break oh my god six commercials you
think that it wasn't allowed to keep
race pure okay okay i know i know okay
okay
you're saying things that are not good
the race pure this is nice
to see i don't think i just i i know
everyone pretty soon is going to be tan
and it's fine not pretty soon we're
talking like 300 million years you know
what i mean that's i don't think so i
think it could be probably 50 to 60
years
so everybody living now is by the time
they're dead they're all going to be the
same color no my point is
am i
watching
peacock
the thing the thing about
mixed race couples is that they really
do exist i know the reason they're in
this is the thing i i don't like though
people get all up in arms about like oh
that's not really how reality is
what commercial is basing itself in
[ __ ] reality dude they're trying to
sell products to as many [ __ ] people
as possible yeah but no dude they do
base themselves in reality dude they do
they'll be in a kitchen and like the dad
will be like uh oh and then a mom will
come in and she'll be like that's
already unrealistic kleenex that's
already unrelated you're supposed to
believe that some [ __ ] family in just
fort wayne indiana like an asian guy is
going to be dating a black chick
it it just find me one in fort wayne
indiana why are you basically why it's
tough to be in fort wayne indiana
not every commercial takes place that's
that's what we did buy untied dude i buy
tide
not in fort wayne indiana have you ever
dated a black check
yeah
yeah
what's the percentage of what of black
girls versus the interracial girls never
done the math on it and guess what if i
did it would be very [ __ ] strange
that would be very [ __ ]
you know i actually know this because i
yeah
all right cool so let's turn on anyway
turn up turn on peacock
dude hit up cbs is on commercial hey
chris hey matt roger justin and brandy
bill were here
uh first of all love your podcast we
appreciate it uh baby since day one hell
yeah
cold all that so we got some uh
baby that we need from you guys so they
got baby socks right there we watch
shows on streaming services netflix
stuff like that
and she has a problem with me watching
shows without her and from my point of
view
she either falls asleep watching them or
just never has time so i'm sitting here
on my day to day like
not doing anything so i just go ahead
and watch them unless she specifically
says that hey i want to watch this
particular show with you yeah so i i i
don't watch that one which there's only
one that she said that but other than
that everything's free game including
lifeline including congratulations she's
not having it is that what she's looking
for
she's like
yeah you're wrong
no all right appreciate it love y'all
i think you i think more publicly should
be interracial you experience this um so
why don't you take it first oh yeah dude
but i have a simple solution but you go
first now you go first i think that
didn't even really work
you took it you said you go first i said
you go first you were already taking a
breath to speak with the quickness so
you weren't even really being polite
even though it was under the guise of
being polite and that's who my brother
is no no no no so
the deal
is has this guy ever heard of a cell
phone well he could just text her first
and say hey honey i want to watch this
show is it going to bother you if i do
that
so he's so he's talking about starting a
new show
no he's talking about in the middle of a
you start a show together we don't know
we don't know it seemed like you said
you start a show together and then in
the middle he wants to watch some
episodes and she's like well you can't
watch it without me that seems like
what's been happening am i wrong here am
i what you always do on the show is you
assume things people said and then
answer that as if they said the thing
that you said instead of the thing that
they actually said is that a listening
problem or is that just a regular
problem well that i have with you this
is an entertainment podcast so i guess
in a way i'd say you're welcome oh okay
we'd bypass all that and i'd let you
know you're welcome dude nice way to
spin that around anyway go ahead and
give your advice what he said yeah
they start watching stuff and she'll
fall asleep yep yeah and then
he wants to keep watching right now she
gets mad that gotcha right you know what
i mean so i was right [ __ ] cool
okay dude that was [ __ ]
the police oh those yeah they were they
were wondering you got to hold them so
fast the [ __ ] truth police called me
i know it's crazy so um but when
somebody put the gun on us and you tried
calling 9-1-1 and they put you on hold
forever i don't remember calling 9-1-1
yeah we were in the car remember i was
going right i remember it happened
on the freeway don't talk over me when i
say that was going reverse on the
freeway remember that and you were
trying to call 9-1-1 and all i kept
thinking is if this [ __ ] shoots
and and hits my brother my life's over
i'm probably going to kill myself shoots
and hits my brother you can just say
with the bullet yeah dude he it was very
weird before we get into this dude
from a very beautiful mixed-race couple
and i think there should be more
mixed-race couples right okay
um
[Music]
and i'm from a mixed race uh thing
because i'm italian and she comes from
like french european descent or some
[ __ ] and uh what do you mean mom we're
talking about mom me you don't come from
mixed races i'm saying from a mixed race
i have a big source relationship you're
in a mixed race yeah because kristen is
i'm italian and i know christian is not
italian i don't want that but from north
carolina so um
so
so this so what was i saying oh yeah
yeah the guy pulled a gun yeah because
you sped up he cut you off for something
you spit up and you go yeah yeah you did
one of those two you're doing going up
yeah i don't like the bitch-ass ones
when they do that yeah they do this like
just this is not strong yeah like this
is strong dude a whopping yeah
[Music]
gross actually okay and um
and so so the guy sped up and pulled a
gun out and started waving it around he
did
and i said i just slowed down and he
slowed down right
to stop us yeah he stopped right in
front of us on the [ __ ] because i was
unwilling to go around him because
bullets yeah yeah and so he
so i was like oh just reverse and i was
very caught dude i you were calm right i
was
my blood pressure i drop it dude because
i was already thinking about the
potential guilt of a bullet hitting you
i get it but i don't flash forward i
stay in the moment okay and i look and i
assess you know because you can't assess
if you're like oh if you're thinking
about my brother might end up dead it's
true i don't do that dude i was not in
good ass there's a scene in one of the
pierce brosnan james bond movies where
he's just on a gurney and he has to act
like he his pulse stops and so he puts
himself into a coma and so they're like
he's dead get him out of here and then
he gets out and they [ __ ] put him in
a body bag and that's how he escapes
because they thought he died because he
put his pulse into a coma the worst
writing of all time well bro
making [ __ ] up you know
how can he get out of this one
how about he stops his own pulse
i don't remember who i was watching this
with but whoever was watching this with
they said like you know you can actually
oh oh it's probably uncle mike i was
gonna say that dude it probably was dude
and so um
so anyway i was like oh you can and so
that was probably what i was trying to
do when the guy pulled the gun on us you
were imagine that happened and i was
just like calm down calm down and i did
and then like
it just shoots me while i'm in a coma
but do you remember how badass the thing
that i ultimately did was
he stopped i stopped cars whizzing by
wasn't buying those and bites in the
middle of the day on a tuesday we had
just voted remember that we voted for
obama thank you very much i don't
remember that and uh i remember he was
reversing with his gun waving it around
and i just went
and i floored it and went around his ass
0-60 in [ __ ] no time and then
he was on my ass he was on our ass and
then i pretended to stay on the 134 at
the very last second right before the
divider
to the five so he had to stand on 134.
okay well liam neeson
okay well my pulse was more like the
amnesia but your pulse was but i was so
in the world more likely i'm decent
so yeah okay all right i don't i don't
know
what my brother dies i was i was i had
nightmares about that [ __ ] i know you're
really really affected and killed yeah
yeah it was [ __ ] up all right so look
i was
i think
look
what
don't like he has you're not always
together in a relationship so that means
that if she falls asleep
and then the next day you go somewhere
to work or whatever the [ __ ] you do
hey girl catch up
you fell asleep catch up to where he is
and then that night you got a [ __ ]
show to watch again yeah but she wants
to watch it with him i guess i know but
but so so so he's got to be what
watching the show and then
making sure when she sleeps you can't do
that you watch a boardwalk empire you're
invested dude what if you're invested
what are you going to do next put on the
show she doesn't want to see but you
don't know when she sleeps is what i'm
saying you're invested with what [ __ ]
lucky johnson or whatever his name is is
doing okay not knocking johnson and then
[ __ ] and then what knock if your buck
is doing and then you're watching and
then she falls asleep but you're
invested dude you're watching ozarks and
you're like is he going to make it out
of that ozarks who are you [ __ ]
grandma carmella just adding an s you're
watching [ __ ] you know
jim you're watching [ __ ] warwick
empires breaking bads
boy meets worlds
you're watching wonder uses the wonder
users and uh
and so you're watching it and then
[ __ ]
you're watching you're you're you're
hell bent you're in the middle of
[ __ ] season three of lucifer's and
then [ __ ] chief you don't know when
she falls asleep on that but because you
don't know yeah okay so
the thing is though
we want to make sure they have a happy
existence together right yeah so maybe
he could look over sometimes if this is
common right maybe he could
learn about some other [ __ ] shows
yeah he's making shows she doesn't care
about and he can watch those [ __ ]
shows when she [ __ ] falls asleep then
he's making her issue which is falling
asleep too soon not just falling asleep
she's also at work and he wants to watch
well no but okay okay so right if
there's actual things that she needs to
be doing then i think that he should
wait for her yes if it's just crazy
kristin
my my because i'm in a interracial i'm
an interracial
and she's so she's from white i know
you're white i know i have an italian
descent right and she is
like i think french or something both
white
whatever it is but she
so
calvin is mixed race right so but like
he sure looks like it
so
so i identify with this couple as what
i'm saying yeah i think a lot of people
do no but because we're both interracial
right so oh okay okay so busted a nut so
oh
oh okay so
what i think is
kristen
now this is a deeper but christian will
be like let's i'll be like let's watch a
new show i should be like great dude i
turn on [ __ ] nookie johnson or
something thompson whatever it is dude
right i know it was based on a real
person okay yeah i'm smart okay and so
i s i so i'm watching the [ __ ] board
boardwalk empire right and i'm looking
at it and we're watching an episode the
episode ends it's [ __ ] gangbusters
right i love boardwalk empire okay i'm
one of those guys that's like why isn't
it [ __ ] considered in with the
sopranos with breaking bad hey grace
first time we've ever agreed about a
show yeah why is it not in with the
[ __ ] breaking bad sopranos [ __ ]
ozark it's legendary uh uh
boy meets why is it not [ __ ] mad man
there we go i didn't like that but you
know what i mean people do
mad men is boring as [ __ ] it's fine okay
going on a tangent keep going right but
it is boring as [ __ ] and everyone just
liked that show because of the [ __ ]
haircuts and the [ __ ] style that it
no and why did i like it not for those
reasons did you ever did you ever
consider that yes i did okay what did
you think secretly you do like it pisses
me off that you're gonna speak for me
and what i [ __ ] you're thinking you're
[ __ ] wrong but keep going
that girl was a good actress in that
that came out and now she's in
handmaid's tale and she's a [ __ ] good
actress but she's a scientologist so
like let's leave it alone talking about
the thing you were talking about though
but so what were we talking about the
mixed race you and kristen so kristen
is like we're watching it and then i say
let's watch another episode and she says
what
and i say let's watch the second episode
and she's like oh okay
we watch the second episode yeah and i
look and at the corner of my eye i see
the [ __ ] she's watching tick tock a
little bit no that's not good fine watch
tick tock a little bit but you're here
with me we're watching nookie johnson
okay okay
thompson second one ends
and i say
dude i was involved in this show at the
end of the first episode yeah
the second now you're waiting i'm away
yeah let's watch a third episode and she
says i don't know
she's not gonna do it
she's not i think maybe i'm gonna go to
bed
okay so she goes to bed yeah but guess
what dude what she's not going to bed
she's in bed uh-huh
she's in bed but her face is glowing
what's that mean she's a poet but she's
not yeah do i describe [ __ ] differently
where are you are you also in bed i'm
watching episode three of [ __ ] lucky
johnson so i'm waiting for a problem so
the problem is the next morning we wake
up and she says
that show's good and i say [ __ ] yeah
night falls and i say let's watch
episode four
and she says well you're already past
one and i say all right well let's watch
episode three again then i guess and she
says
nah
and now i'm involved in a show and i
gotta watch it alone dude okay
and i'm pissed because we were supposed
to have this [ __ ] juncture together
but it's okay to watch stuff
but alone the next night she comes down
and she's like let's watch something
else and i'm like you just want to watch
[ __ ] three episodes of some [ __ ]
die okay we finally got to a problem
obviously maybe it's something that
actual
interracial couples experience more
because you're saying if it's if you
guys are any indication being a mixed
race couple okay um i think that texture
before when you're alone texting and be
like hey i wanted to watch this show i
know you're at work is that cool like
did you want to watch it if you do i'll
wait for you that's easy just do that
but that's fine but then he doesn't know
when she's falling asleep she falls
asleep and he's still watching the show
and then he's got to re-watch it no when
he wakes up and he goes to work and she
goes to work if she comes back earlier
you catch up dude but
how about this look over sometimes
you're invested in what the [ __ ] is
going on when you're watching fear thy
neighbor or whatever the [ __ ] show
you're watching dad invested look over
once every 20 minutes dude
look over
i'm probably not
all right next one
hey chris and matt i need we have a lot
of ginger fans
really don't want to end up on fear thy
neighbor and i feel like i might luckily
i don't live in atlanta so
maybe i'm safe i don't know maybe um
husband and i have lived in the house
that we're in for eight months uh one of
our neighbors never seen her never talk
to her don't know what she looks like
so
um
one morning it's like 6 30 a.m and both
my kids are asleep husband and i are
asleep
there's this crazy loud banging on our
door
and i look at the ring camera no idea
who this woman is she's just got one
single crutch and she's like swaying
outside super weird um at 6 30 and so my
husband goes to the door asks her what
she needs and she tells us that we are
sabotaging her sleep schedule because we
are timing our car alarms to go off
every morning at the same time
that's not true does it well don't set
off our car alarms she's clearly crazy
yeah
whoa
what do i do i love how it ended what do
i do
um what do you do what you do is
say this okay i got it okay say this say
if she comes over again and accuses you
of that say you're on my property
if you come over here and accuse me of
something that i'm
that i've not done ever again
i'll [ __ ] kill you no that's
you can't threaten i mean she's a
candidate you're on your property and
you don't want it yeah if somebody's
being crazy on your property it's kind
of scary
you have self-defense just be like i'm
warning you if you do this again you
come out here accusing me of [ __ ] that i
obviously don't do i'll [ __ ] kill you
and go to bed sleep like a baby
that's bad okay maybe not kill you
break your up she rolls up with her
[ __ ] crutch
and she says hey you're setting your car
alarm that's timing you can't even do
that by the way i know you're setting
you're timing your car alarms off to go
together like why the [ __ ] would she
even want that to be happening right
well to sabotage this is how i wake up
sorry dude my alarms don't work i gotta
use my car right right
i mean hey someone
bicycle up to my car and throw a brick
at the hood every morning
right
whoever designed that [ __ ]
music song is [ __ ] so foreign music
is absolutely rolling in it dude i made
that i made that song that [ __ ]
so uh
what's your advice
when she comes up and she says hey
you're you're scheduling your car alarms
to go off you say you're a dragon right
because no no no
because i'm not done talking right i
thought you were
well now but you'll say i'm a dragon and
she says no i'm not and i say so we're
both liars
or so we're both equally right yeah yeah
well but shorten it up right no what i
said is better so we're both liars no
yeah okay yeah yeah
yeah and then kick her crutch out from
under and watch her stand fine see now
you know she's alive right yeah yeah
yeah i think that honestly that's
uh yeah you should say you i think the
the real thing is you just gotta be like
i'm not doing that you gotta get off my
property
right yeah you're coming at me hostile
you're accusing me of something that's
not happening you're on my property you
gotta get off and and absolutely do not
make the mistake of doing it again
because what you wanna do is avoid it in
the future cause she's crazy she's gonna
continue to think it none of it matters
what she thinks just you want to stop
her from coming over and saying it or
ringing your doorbell ever people are
delusional huh like yeah you know what i
mean have your husband behind the door
on the right when she comes in and says
that and then and then she says hello
and she says yeah you're timing your
you're you're sabotaging my sleep have
the husband just in your shots say is
that the neighbor again that'll be very
creepy too and she probably won't come
by she's old though she won't even
[ __ ] hear it all people can't hear
anything is she old
i'm assuming if she's gonna crush and
it's crazy who's assuming all right next
one
chris and matt what's going on guys i
just want to say i love you guys
appreciate what you guys do all the
advice you give and
chris your comedy is hysterical man
please come to st louis we need you here
i will but i got a bit of a question for
you guys today um i work for a pool
company and some of the pools we clean
are really hard to access
and uh one pool in particular has a hill
in their backyard that we have to go
down with our equipment and it's muddy
it's mulchy and it's covered in dog [ __ ]
um covered like it's an unreasonable
amount and they won't pick it up i've
left door hangers i've left voicemails
i've knocked on the door and asked them
to specifically pick it up the guy comes
out and he goes yeah i don't really have
time i have 15 kids blah blah blah i
said 15 kids if you have 15 kids you
don't need a dog
but i just don't know what to do about
it because it gets on my equipment and
my shoes and i you know can't really do
anything about it i'm not going to pick
up the poop for them so uh if you guys
got any advice let me know appreciate it
peace i do is it is it 1860 because why
does he have 15 kids it's only you only
have 15 kids if it's 1860 oh he's in
utah here's my advice
the guy has 15 kids put one of them to
work to pick up the dog [ __ ] yeah that's
really a good idea you're 15 of them
what are you doing there's one out of
15. put seven of them to work
immediately but also dude like if you
have a pool guy i would bet
you have a gardener
so right
the gardener should be figuring that out
i mean the guy look it doesn't matter
the guy is being asked to pick up his
dog [ __ ] because someone who comes to
you but it is his house i know but he
has 15 kids
yeah look it's it's it's one of those
things that's like dude be a buddy man
pick up the [ __ ] you're making me trudge
through horseshit i think honestly the
move for real i know i think i know what
you're going to do yeah you do the move
is yeah to be out there
and just
take a [ __ ] [ __ ]
right where the [ __ ] dog shits are
okay and be there long enough to where
the guy comes out and he says what are
you doing and then you say
this is the place where you take
[ __ ]
clearly yeah
so i'm just doing what you'd like me to
do underst yeah because i've really got
to go to the bathroom and the thing i
was going to say is pick it pick it up
and put it all in the pool
you're going to get fired well that's
maybe a good reason not to do it um
uh just [ __ ] where the [ __ ] is bro
now that's disgusting dude he wouldn't
even care though he would just let it
stay there and then you got to come back
and you're
all your [ __ ] as well it's kind of a
lose-lose just
i don't know
pick it up and put it on the door like
near the doorway right so he has to
clean it up right right right yeah
that's rough dude i say take a [ __ ]
where they you know i would say like
forge a path like sweep the [ __ ] out of
the way
and just create a path for you to be
able to walk through that is shitless
and then what the dogs are going to [ __ ]
there and the next time it's going to be
there maybe ew dude doesn't it smell so
bad also was that an exaggeration does
this guy have [ __ ] 15 kids dude if
you have 15 kids you
are
just living wrong you know what i mean
get snipped dude he's religious for sure
yeah he is he's also in 1860 yeah which
is hard to
reason with someone from
that is living 160 years before you you
know what i mean mm-hmm it's hard to
reason with that yeah i understand that
yeah all right will we really help that
guy go ahead next
hi matt hi beautiful here i absolutely
love you guys i have been a baby since
day one the cult is diverse
so i live a pretty unconventional life
um as a digital nomad i've wanted to be
a nomad for a very long time so this is
kind of my dream situation
i absolutely love it
i am an accounting consultant um and i
absolutely love that
relationship wise i have
recognized
at some point before my digital nomad
journey that i'm just not cut out for
relationships when i do decide to talk
to
um guys which isn't often i usually try
to set boundaries right away i don't
want to like lead anyone on or hurt
anybody but i met a guy that i
think i might be falling for i think
about him way too much and he's just
he's been a total gentleman
and i think he really likes me too so i
feel like
he wants a relationship and he's a
relationship guy i can tell so what do
you think i'm thinking that
it's probably unsafe to keep talking to
him because i don't see a situation long
term where we both would be satisfied um
thank you so much you guys are awesome
oh sweet yeah uh-huh yeah i don't know
either no i guess we'll find it all
right
dude that was webster
he doesn't know what a digital nominated
either
[Laughter]
dude what the [ __ ] is a digital nomad
chris
what it's when you work from wherever
you are you know people like work
remotely some people do that and they
just
are always traveling she was really
really really pushing that [ __ ] like she
was trying to sell some merch with
digital nomad on it
she should start a podcast called
all right well look yeah okay um so you
travel a lot and uh you're a digital
nomad and that's cool and you met this
dude and you really like him but you
know sometimes look here's the deal dude
um sometimes things this is so basic but
it's just so true things change you like
this guy and maybe you want to explore
something different in your life you
know what i mean maybe you want to
[ __ ] hang out with this guy maybe you
want a date you know he's a relationship
type guy but relationships don't work
for you but guess what dude knocking on
your door is change open it up and maybe
just maybe you will find it fulfilling
in your digital nomad life that you
might want a relationship and you'll be
a digital stay-at-home mom
the thing uh
just is just to stay open the thing that
bothers me but that people do is they're
like i'm not like that so that thing
that i've never tried and never
experienced and never let happen in one
way in one form or another is just not
gonna work for me like how the [ __ ] do
you even know yep if you liked the guy
and he likes you and the relationship is
possible on the horizon uh don't be like
oh i don't get into relationships oh i
don't like relationships all
relationships don't work for me you
don't know you haven't [ __ ] dated
this guy before give it a shot
at least [ __ ] try
see what happens my whole thing is just
things change man okay we said that i
know but like that doesn't change it
doesn't change but
but it does change like you think one
way and then another thing happens and
then dude you never know you know you
just never know give it a shot it might
be love dude
you know
try it out let it go let it happen see
if you can be happy see if it works give
yourself a chance give him a chance give
life a chance
it's not about being giving him a chance
it's about giving yourself a chance
isn't it oh we are safe
that was horrible the way you're saying
that is give him a chance
you look great today man yeah outfit on
fleek hair looks good nice wow fleek i
haven't thought of that you look
don't really consider myself a little
bit of a caffeine addict
but um i have around three cups a day
and if it's not a cup of coffee i only
get ice americano really makes my uh
motor go however i'm experiencing either
one of two things that happen i crash
really hard around like three from like
a workday or
i can't fall asleep i'm wide awake like
i feel like my eyes are wide awake while
i'm trying to sleep so i've been trying
to wind it back down to maybe one cup a
day but i'm so unproductive i'm sitting
here making
videos for this podcast uh while i
should be working one way i guess what's
a happy medium
how many cups are like good for you guys
what do you guys settle with and how do
you avoid that like zigzag of ups and
downs or just staying up all night
thanks
look bro you're my guy like i would hang
with this guy yeah this guy's like three
cups of coffee
keeps me [ __ ] awake
one cup of coffee
completely i i'm too tired all day
how many cups of coffee should i have
two is this a children's show calvin
would be like
two here's the thing though
there's too much one is enough
here's something though too if you want
to keep it at one your body will get
used to it just ride it [ __ ]
come on come on write it out you know
what i mean
write it out write it out write it out
write it out but also
if you want to know about me because
since he asked they did he did he asked
i drink a pot of coffee when i wake up i
drink a potato drink a pot of coffee
right after that i drink a lot of coffee
throughout the rest of the day and i'll
drink two cups of coffee right before
bed and i will fall the [ __ ] asleep and
it won't matter that i just drink coffee
really yeah you literally have been
complaining about not being able to
sleep it has nothing to do with coffee
uh
that's
that's through with anxiety and there's
a trust
and a deep deep disillusionment with the
world and the nine
pots of coffee i drink all day and also
the nine pots of coffee i drink all day
no but seriously though uh but that's
just me that is very uncommon nobody
that i know is like that
you
drink two cups
to find that happy balance
is what i think you were saying yeah no
but this is the greatest if you want to
cut it down in general
your body will readjust to just the one
but he doesn't want to cut it down
necessarily well he actually did say
yeah he's trying to cut it down yeah
yeah if you're trying to cut down your
body will readjust just give it a minute
try two
try two
yeah that's very obvious try two yeah uh
wow i wish i was with you and i could be
like dude [ __ ] you're saying too many
is three is too many ones
i've tried two you [ __ ] idiot and we
would have a good time dude laughing
yeah he would laugh i would love that
dude he looks like a good guy he's got
good hair yeah you know he's blonde
what's up with that i know well blonde
people can't blond dudes can't wear
leather jackets unless they're brown but
anyway i've i might have to come around
on blonde guys because that guy no dude
blond dudes are very handsome they're
just
not sexy he was sexy he was kind of sexy
but if he was brunette imagine if he was
brunette dude i don't know he looked
uniquely he had like the jake bucy thing
going on and i think he looked hot
jake bucy is not hot dude he was like a
hot jake bucy okay okay well what about
[ __ ] chris hemsworth dude handsome
yeah he kind of looked like pretty sexy
chris evans there's an example of a
blonde dude that is handsome and just
zero sexy christian
no chris evans because evans isn't
blonde he is blonde what the [ __ ] he was
captain america captain america's blonde
no he's not dude he's blonde yes
brunette no [ __ ] he's dirty
blonde trying to gaslight me dude he's
dirty blonde at best i'm not standing
for it pull up a picture of what happens
dude chris evans is [ __ ] uh
he's got zero
uh
uh well click on one
click on one make it bigger well that's
obviously blonde that that honestly
that's died though yeah he's gonna move
go to go go to like look at him brunette
that's yeah i guess it kind of is but
he's got like a ginger feel to him okay
but he's got brunette hair
i guess he kind of does huh yeah
he's blonde
he you know what he feels blonde yeah
he's not that's worse
to actually have the good [ __ ] but seem
blonde yeah but imagine if he was blonde
dude just seriously he'd be like what's
that you'd be around and be like what's
that noise
it'd be all the pieces drying up yeah
yeah yeah you gotta bleep it out so the
guy on the episode the guy that called
in is way hotter than chris evans of
course he's blonde of course of course
but yeah two cops
okay okay next
oh look at that what's up matt what's up
chris jonathan from alabama long time
listener i mean you're not right
you're not so not in alabama
am i right right i mean and it's fine to
be there because maybe you've been there
for a while but if you're gonna say i'm
from alabama in that way
clear it up afterwards or clear up where
you're really from boy yeah you're
[ __ ] get on this is michael from
mississippi
hello i am from absolutely anywhere but
russia
[Laughter]
dude
okay so we get it you live in alabama
we're having some fun with you but you
look great in your pink lips right sorry
that's a secret edition special edition
that you can't get anymore and this guy
[ __ ] scooped it up dude all right
this guy's lips though he's a good guy
yeah i like this guy i would immediately
hang out with gekko yeah
with my brother i have
a italian restaurant and um
that makes sense all the time together
but he doesn't seem to understand the
value of downtime and
hobbies and relaxing
um maybe you can give me some advice and
tell him how to chill without me
sounding preachy yeah uh and just how
you guys deal with uh
over work
yeah um
see you september 9 in atlanta
live rips hell yeah
you're the man right that's cool this
guy seems like such a sweet dude um i
actually i i sympathize with what he's
saying because people that i love that
i'm close to that are true workaholics
that don't know how to calm down it
makes me anxious and it makes me worried
about them because you got to [ __ ]
chill out otherwise you're going gonna
die at 55. yeah you know what i mean
so work isn't everything but the way to
convey that to the guy is tricky because
maybe he's defensive maybe he doesn't
have anything he's definitely expensive
i was talking you know what i mean i was
talking when he discovered me right go
ahead uh and so i think that maybe
there's a way to
at first at least
on oops
on your downtime
invite him along and don't let don't
take no for an answer you know what i
mean
my whole thing about these dudes that
just go go go go go like
for what
you're you're for what for more money
for more
you're only
running from something that's what i
mean i think that yeah they can't answer
that because the truth is they don't
realize to do right
it's like an addict it's akin to being
an addict yes i know people who do this
and quite frankly they're
awful they're awful to be around why is
it they're just they're always working
and you're like oh i can't hang out with
that person yeah it's they're annoying
they're always talking and saying
something [ __ ] about work and it's
just like okay you're not a real person
to me i'm not saying that's what your
brother is like i don't know your
brother but there is such value in chill
time if he has a family i don't know
well he obviously has some family i mean
you're his brother but like yeah yeah
invite him along to your [ __ ]
and say dude try this with me i'm with
your bro i'm your brother let's just
take a [ __ ] chill day
[ __ ] this
fake italian restaurant because we're
obviously not italian right and we're in
alabama we're so confused right let's
figure out who we are
and let's do this now i think that uh i
think that
you also could if you want to you could
say if you don't want to sound preachy
you could say dude i'm just like i'm a
little i'm not like worried about you
but like it concerns me that you all you
ever want to do is work all you ever
care about is work like maybe we could
you could hang out with me we could do
some stuff this and that whatever but
like if you come from a place of concern
rather than like this is how you should
live your life i think that that's
there's a big difference in that and
someone who's prone to being defensive
will get less defensive if you're coming
out of a place of concern yeah or
they'll just be like it's fine don't
worry and then you're like oh okay but
anyway yeah maybe but i'm just giving
the guy options all right yeah let's get
the noodles from the van then okay well
all right
see you in uh atlanta chris matt what's
up love the show
chris huge fan of congratulations going
on your show
in boston in
november for it so me and my girlfriend
are having a baby boy in two weeks
and my question for you guys is what do
you think about godparents is it
necessary to have them we're not really
religious
so we're not too stressed about it but a
lot of people are asking us and at this
point it almost seems like a tradition
so yeah we just want to know what you
guys think do we need to have them and
uh
thank you for everything thanks for the
show life rips
bye
hell yeah it's so cute
racial couple um
so uh i think that's great i didn't
realize we were watching peacock tv
that's all
well do you have advice
uh you have a kid
i do you're his godfather
yeah uh
that's nothing really you know so why
did you do it
because of tradition and i want
you
to be as close to him as possible
because you're my brother and i want if
it means something to him later on down
the line i want him to have that and i
want him to have it with you
almost teared up i think the thing about
kept it in check i think the thing about
godparents is less about religion and
more about um
like the idea of responsibility in in
the parents absence if something
happened to you there would be this like
not legal not binding responsibility but
spiritual
uh responsibility for your son i will
always look out for calvin because you i
mean obviously i would anyway but you
know the idea of a godparent is if
anything were to happen to the actual
parent the godparent will always be
there no matter what because you have
that person's word because you love them
and because you're close to them and
what are you doing i'm not even going to
look tell me what you're doing right now
you zoomed into my face when you were
talking it was only on me oh let's go
down here let's get down anxiety okay uh
yeah i think that that the i i think god
parent is misleading because people that
don't understand or have never done it
think it's religious but it's not it's
not it's just like this this like well
the word god is in it you know yeah it
might as well be [ __ ] it's very
religious but it's not it's not really
religious to you no it's just like
it's just like a a a it's kind of a
beautiful thing that parents can do to
sort of say without a lot of words you
are sort of like the backup parent yeah
background
that's good call it backup parent if you
don't want to do it don't do it but like
you know don't feel pressure but if you
feel like doing it there's someone in
your life that you think you'd sort of
want to bestow the honor on do it it's
[ __ ] valentine's day it's a hallmark
[ __ ] you know what i mean it's like it
means something but it doesn't really
mean something unless you die in a plane
crash next
wow
you'll be fine bro you know what it
might mean something to the kids so why
don't you just do it if you have someone
who's obviously clearly going to be the
person then just do it yeah right if not
then that's some difficult decision yeah
hey chris and matt i love what you guys
do thank you for all the awesome
episodes and uh i hope you can answer my
question two months ago i matched with a
girl and we have so much in common more
than any other girl that i've dated and
i've been around the block so that tells
me a lot uh we've been talking on the
phone and texting daily i speak russian
fluently so that's no issue i have an
attorney from alabama i'm a [ __ ] and i
gained feelings for her and so did she
uh she actually asked me if i could come
and visit her and seeing as there's a
ton of strict sanctions in russia um i
could go there but that would not be any
good for me since my credit card and
debit card simply will not work so
clearly that's off the menu so by the
looks of it i have two options i stopped
talking to her or i wait until the war
ends and the banking systems go back
into play but
honestly who knows how long that'll be
so what do you recommend i do should we
try and make this work or should i stop
wasting her time i can tell she wants to
keep it going because the second she
wakes up
to go to work she texts me the second
she gets home from work she calls me uh
she sends me photos of her family or her
nieces uh her nephews her her mom her
sisters i mean we're really close and so
i can tell she wants to keep it going
but i'm not exactly sure she understands
that i probably won't see her for quite
a long time which goes back to me asking
myself
should i just end this now and stop
wasting her time
or or not maybe the answer is obvious
and i'm overthinking but i would love
your guys's input thank you
here's my impression of this guy right
now
you're getting taken for a ride
why
well he's not giving her money yeah but
dude that's what it's leading to dude
she's giving him [ __ ] pictures of his
her niece and [ __ ] like that's way too
much info it's way too much info it's
not real dude this is this dude right
here
you gotta take it for a ride
i actually didn't even think that i
don't think i agree she's not asking him
for money dude not yet dude because
right now it's just like this i'm gonna
add a caveat to everything i'm saying i
i i
if she ever asks you for money
then everything i'm saying
flushes down the [ __ ] toilet but what
i would say is came what i would say is
you [ __ ]
uh
what i don't like what i don't like is
when [ __ ] like take it upon
themselves to decide for some woman to
be like oh you don't know what you're
getting into like she's not a [ __ ]
adult she's an adult she can decide
whatever the [ __ ] she wants if you don't
want to keep doing it then you don't do
it but don't take her agency away from
her and be like
you don't know what you're getting into
sweetheart trust me this is a way bigger
deal than you realize i'm going to cut
i'm going to cut the cord now because
you don't know what you're getting into
don't do that it's not your
responsibility it's your responsibility
to look out for you and don't be a
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] too hard now if
she asks you for money you're gonna take
it for a ride and you're a [ __ ] idiot
and i can tell you want to say something
because you won't stop moving so go
ahead
that's my is that my
dude that's him i think you missed my
but nothing's happened yet
that's why he's
he's not like let me out
yeah but a lot of guys willfully give
women money that they've never met
before right and that's fine but dude my
point is you gotta dude you have to just
you're get you're why can't she can she
come see him i was gonna say get her the
[ __ ] out of russia get her out of her
hey dude go away
from the war part yeah
and also go away get the people you love
away from the war
why are you wanting to go over there you
guys talk about debit and credit cards
you're gonna die dude don't go to russia
you [ __ ] my question is here is the
deal i can speak russian fluently i love
when bullets are whizzing by my head
sometimes i love when bullets hit my
head um i would like to go to russia is
this a good idea since i am so in love
with bullets riddling my body and
whizzing by my head and sometimes
hitting my head they're not fighting you
guys in russia i know i know i know i
get it so but also it's a bad idea to go
to russia while russia is waging a
[ __ ] war yeah dude on ukraine and
potentially uh more of the world
obviously don't do that
full stop if she's so [ __ ] into you
as well
get her the [ __ ] out of there and have
her join you wherever you are in [ __ ]
alabama or wherever you are just take
the seat belt off buddy and get out
this is a ride one way or another it is
dude also there's people around you hey
guy
look yeah just go outside you should
look closer than right now i mean dude
it couldn't be further
i am on a dating app that is actually
intergalactical um i met this person who
was four foot six and she is on pluto
and it's uh it is weird kind of face
timing her because her helmet gets in
the way i have not seen her full face
she is green her nose is astronomically
big and she has three penises but those
are the females on pluto uh i want to go
out there i'm not quite sure if my debit
card will work
i mean dude do you hear yourself
do me a favor play this back
[Laughter]
don't go to russia you [ __ ] idiot i
mean dude just stay around where you are
and find a sweetheart there or have her
come to you and yeah the [ __ ] pen
true true split the cost yeah true split
the cost right
okay
the [ __ ] ah this oh we saw this
guy before
i don't know
uh thanks for answering my question
about yeah i should do the horizontal
mambo with my co-workers yeah yeah
you know that i didn't try to pursue
anything nice but you know
door's open oh this is yeah um but i do
have a i have another question for you
guys
now
i got a nice gift when i graduated high
school this was you know
six seven years ago
and you know it cost a lot of money
but it was a portrait of myself
whoa wow and my mom didn't want it my
dad didn't want it oh that's a picture
so i just put it up in my office but now
when i i mean it's mostly ironically but
when i take zoom calls
yep well it doesn't look like you
anymore that's over my shoulder so
they'd be like why is daniel tosh behind
you what do you do when someone gives
you a gift that you don't want and you
can't even pawn it off on somebody wow
that's perfect yeah because this thing
it's got to go thanks guys uh give it to
the co-worker that you have a crush on
it and be like do you like this
do you like the guy in this you know and
like
so you don't have to like you can't be
accused of anything
crash or cross at the workplace yeah but
you can if she says no and gets offended
be like that's not me and if she says
yes i'll be like okay so you like this
guy and then hold it up next to you and
see if she sees the similarity and [ __ ]
like that that's hilarious that that
somebody gave you a picture of yourself
of you that big and it's a picture not a
painting
that's a photo it's a photo yeah i guess
it was yeah dude um yeah toss it i mean
i'm not cinnamon [ __ ] get rid of that
why would you want to keep that toss it
throw it rip it up first so people don't
[ __ ] see it in the trash can burn it
and do like a thing
like cast away like yeah castaway yeah
okay cool burn it
all right you want to burn it sanders
burn it sanders
no not burn it burn it sanders we cannot
burn it say that
saw you in phoenix you absolutely killed
it i'm just gonna tell you um just like
you're my friend um so um i come from a
very catholic family pray the rosary
church every day that type of catholic
anyways i um left the church and now i'm
getting married
and um we are both um
do not want to get married in the
catholic church
um but that has kind of created a lot of
you answered your question already and
tension in the family where um people
are like we're not gonna go to the
wedding because that's a mortal sin to
not get married in the church wow um
so
i need your advice like is it even like
worth throwing a wedding where like your
family
will show up and like be kind of
unhappy about it or they won't come and
then i'll feel bad or
i guess i just i don't know what to do
should we just elope
i think maybe i was going to say maybe a
little because they're not grateful they
don't care about you or respect you
hello enough to go to your [ __ ]
wedding just because not at the catholic
church and they let them know that they
can be catholic all they want but let
them know that the rest of the world
finds the catholic church just as
synonymous with [ __ ]
child molesters and [ __ ] raping kids
than it does with [ __ ] god and
priests like they need to get their
[ __ ] head checked and realize the
catholic church is not what they [ __ ]
used to remember it as oh well yeah
they're old school though yeah but
that's why she needs to [ __ ] tell him
yeah i'd also say
like if you disrespect me that much and
won't even come to my wedding then [ __ ]
you i'm going to vegas yeah [ __ ] yeah
yeah
elope a lobe for sure yeah dude do you
got to do what you want to do this is a
wedding and i know i know
a lot of times people think like
weddings the wedding is really for
everyone else but it's not dude it's for
you dude it's a beautiful time in your
life you know i just got married and
like you get to share that moment with
that person and it's a memory that
you're going to create with them dude
and uh you got to do it yourself you got
to do it for yourself don't get married
in the church dude don't get married in
the church you're going to [ __ ] talk
about resentment you're going to be
resent yeah resentful to your [ __ ]
family for pressuring you for doing
something that you didn't want to do on
a day that's supposed to be your [ __ ]
day yeah yeah and you know what
sometimes i come in and i just hit the
[ __ ] truth with the hammer right okay
i mean sometimes i do jokings and [ __ ]
and sometimes i [ __ ] make fun of
people but sometimes i come in and i
just [ __ ] hit the truth of the hammer
and that's what you gotta do dude and
that's what's good about me i think i
hit the truth of the hammer before you
did
i started hitting the word i started
image i used i started hitting the truth
of the hammer and then you joined in
because you're a follower i hit the
truth of the hammer you were like kind
of like saying the truth but i hit the
truth of the hammer nope the truth with
the hammer i hit it with a sledgehammer
what's going on where were you she that
that lady by the way yeah had a
fantastic nose she did and she also said
really nice glasses they remind me of
this pair of my glasses okay but i'm
being nicer because her nose is actually
part of her face and you're just saying
that accessories don't take it from me
i'm saying her nose that nose is a great
nose okay okay i [ __ ] love her nose
okay relax but i'm just saying no that's
it okay we've got another one
hello can i take your order
i'm reaching out because i just got
engaged
and we are getting married in april
and obviously i'm the girl so i'm
planning it and i have no idea what i'm
doing and i don't know what matters i
don't know what people actually care
about
and what do you do you have any advice
on weddings what matters because there's
so many things that you're supposed to
do
any regrets any do's or don'ts um
like flower girls and first like first
look
and the garter belt like do you do the
flower toss and do we care we actually
care
did you do that
so that's my question also for invites
like if anyone didn't make the cut
should i say something or do i just move
on because they didn't make it same as
bridal party do i say you were so close
i'm sorry that was just not fun
your friends aren't applying anyways
thank you so much any advice is helpful
also weird side no i actually know
people that were at your wedding
really weird
whoa
um
you don't give a [ __ ] about any of the
things so then don't do any of them i
don't like this thing about like what am
i supposed to do what does the world
think i should do for my wedding who the
[ __ ] [ __ ] cares do whatever the [ __ ]
you want doesn't matter a wedding is
[ __ ] nothing
oh wow it's just
the worst advice of all the a wedding a
wedding is just
the quickness of going from just to the
sound
is so stupid the wedding is just all
right look dude
tourette syndrome so she
uh
don't do this is my advice
save whatever of the money you can do it
just don't add [ __ ] that you don't want
to add because you feel like you should
first of all period second of all it's
just gonna you're
you're gonna that comes out of your
pocket
use that use the tips you're getting
from waitressing to [ __ ]
put in a down payment on a [ __ ] house
we already have a house but not whatever
the [ __ ] you know what i mean
what another house something that is
useful get a [ __ ] car get a
jackhammer do something with it weddings
[ __ ] piss me off dude the whole thing
about the way people are about weddings
the way [ __ ] parents make it about
them dude what the [ __ ] sneaker who the
[ __ ] [ __ ] gives a [ __ ] it's deeper
all right yeah just you save your money
dude
oh my god
save your money
all right well that's good you guys we
had a great episode and remember i'll be
in [ __ ] dallas grand prairie whatever
the [ __ ] um and uh atlanta georgia i'll
see that guy in the pink the [ __ ]
fake that had the the guy from russia
pretending to be from alabama i'll see
him in alabama or in atlanta georgia
whoops that's alabama but he know he
said he'd be there in atlanta yeah
you're not going to alabama i'm going to
atlanta georgia september 9th wichita
kansas washington dc
stockton california i'll be in [ __ ]
raleigh rockford cheyenne
boston massachusetts albany lakeland
florida and jackson florida jacksonville
florida chrisley.com you got a question
for us click the link in the description
below or just go straight to watch
lifeline.com
and here's the other thing too dude
subscribe to super cult the channel
subscribe to our channel leave a [ __ ]
uh message under the comments and uh
absolutely just [ __ ] take that like
button out on a date
uh thanks guys for listening
bye-bye thank you love you
hello
[Music]